[Musique]
la fin de l'hiver approche et c'est
l'occasion bout les russes de célébrer
maslenitsa je me trouve ici dans sa
capitale autoproclamée de iaroslav
allons voir comment les russes accueille
le début des beaux jours c'est sur la
place principale de yaroslavl au son de
musiques folkloriques et de danses
traditionnelles que les rues sont venus
célébrer maslenitsa équivalent du mardi
gras c'est une fête aux origines
païennes et qui empruntent des traits à
la religion orthodoxe précédé par le
grand carême la fête marque la fin de
l'hiver et le début du printemps
l'occasion pour les russes de se régaler
les papilles avec des blini ses fines
crêpes
elles sont un plat incontournable de
massinissa symbolisant le soleil tant
attendu je n'ai pas attendu longtemps
pour mettre la main à la pâte et
confectionné mes premiers bling un vrai
plaisir gustatif et olfactif
voilà
voilà on a peut-être bien la presse et
film
[Musique]
la taz un gars seraient ensuite voilà et
environs l'appli en gaz forte
[Musique]
voilà m et une hôpitaux d'amendé et avec
un peu de crème fraîche
je passe des choses mais c'est délicieux
une crêpe cette maison délicieux vas-y
la bonne chose
[Musique]
après la pause gourmande place un peu
d'activité physique lors de masse limite
ça c'est la coutume de s'adonner à des
jeux traditionnels mais pas loin de la
place centrale un immense terrain offre
une multitude de jeux la tâche est plus
ardue que je ne le pensais
[Musique]
et sans oublier le combat traditionnel
russe à mains nues
je danse vont certes
vraiment superbe et tuba
cette fête est appréciée tant par les
petits que par les grands c'est une
superbe fête pour les enfants pour leur
montrer nos traditions anciennes
comment cette fête était toujours
célébré ont fait de la luge
on s'amuse et on mange des petites
bandes crac la crêpe symbolise le soleil
une fête belle et chaleureuse
une fête chaleureuse au sens littéral
aussi célébré dans les quatre coins du
pays pendant une semaine entière elle
s'achève par un immense feu de joie
autour duquel les rues se réunissent
afin de faire leurs adieux à l'hiver ils
ne veulent raté pour rien ce spectacle
impressionnant
[Applaudissements]
la poupée le match fini ça qui
représente l'hiver brûle et
officiellement le printemps